[Aplausos]
las conferencias en otro lugar y me
acuerdo esta primera noche apenas hace
un par de noches
bolt y como cada noche a abrazar a mi
esposa y darle un beso de buenas noches
y abrazarla solo para darme cuenta que
no estaba allí ahora ya sabía que no
estaba allí pero por instinto me volteé
para abrazarla no si la pasó alguna vez
eso que sientes que tienes algo y sabes
que está ahí pero no está ahí te falta
tienes esa ausencia esa necesidad como
algunos de pronto no saben dónde está su
celular y se vuelven hiper ansiosos
necesitan necesitan incluso pastillas
para esa ansiedad porque no está el
celular
sabes esta necesidad o ausencia o sentir
que algo te falta puede ser algo muy
profundo también lo veo en los niños
huérfanos tengo tres hijos dos de ellos
son mis hijos biológicos mi hija la
menor sofía es mi hija por adopción y
cuando la conocimos hace algunos años
visitábamos la casa hogar y tú podías
ver la cara de tantos niños allí que
aunque tenían techo tenían comida tenían
algún cuidado en sus ojos podías ver una
ausencia una falta una necesidad como
que ellos saben me hace falta papá me
hace falta mamá y aunque hay huérfanos
que quizás viven con algún familiar con
una abuelita aún así ellos necesitan y
lo puedes ver en sus ojos y sus
conversaciones necesitan a papá
necesitan a mamá y una necesidad
universal que todos los seres humanos
tenemos es esta necesidad de ser feliz
queremos ser felices y andamos buscando
un montón de cosas para hacernos feliz
decimos si tengo éxito eso me va a ser
feliz y luego tienes quizás el logro o
el éxito que querías y no eres feliz al
índice si esa chica fuera mi novia sería
feliz pero ya es su novia bueno si me
caso con ella sería feliz luego se casan
bueno si tuviera hijos sería feliz luego
tim hijos si fueras soltero ahora sí
sería feliz es como que siempre hay un
rango después y si mi empresa por este
tamaño y luego movemos el rango el
doctor
eres un psicólogo zone creel dice que
tenemos la fórmula de la felicidad al
revés que nosotros queremos lograr
felicidad al conseguir éxito pero que
realmente es al revés que para tener
éxito tenemos que primero ser felices
que primero tenemos que sentirnos
felices es más estudios muestran que
somos 37% más productivos más efectivos
más creativos si nos sentimos felices o
sea que este esta idea de que algún día
voy a ser feliz cuando tenga esa casa
tengo ese carro tienes éxito no va a
suceder porque siempre vas a querer algo
más que te haga feliz y entonces primero
tenemos que ser felices para producir el
éxito que queremos en nuestro matrimonio
nuestra familia nuestra carrera lo que
sea que queremos lograr pero por qué
tenemos este sentir esta idea esta
hambre de felicidad
sabes nuestro cuerpo
nos dice que necesitamos comer y como
nos dice eso tenemos hambre nuestra
mente nos dice que necesitamos
información o que necesitamos
entretenimiento porque de pronto nuestra
mente se aburre y nuestro cuerpo
necesita alimentarse nuestra mente
también necesita alimento pero esto de
la felicidad porque lo sentimos porque
queremos ser felices hay una ausencia
una añoranza de querer ser feliz es como
que ese paraíso perdido que buscamos y
se nos escapa es algo que no podemos
agarrar porque sentimos esa ausencia esa
necesidad yo propongo que como seres
humanos tenemos un cuerpo tenemos una
mente pero también tenemos un espíritu y
nuestro espíritu no se está diciendo
tengo hambre hay algo más allá aparte de
lo que podemos ver y de lo que podemos
conocer y lograr nuestro espíritu tiene
hambre de otra cosa el problema es que
no sabemos cómo alimentar nuestro
espíritu sabemos cómo alimentar el
cuerpo sabemos cómo alimentar nuestra
mente pero no sabemos cómo alimentar
y espíritu y llevo como 20 años
trabajando ayudando a personas desde
nuestro punto de trabajo y somos parte
de una iglesia y ayudamos a mucha gente
aconsejamos a mucha gente y yo me dado
cuenta a través de los años que hay tres
cosas que alimentan tu espíritu
hay cosas que te hacen sentir placer
pero hay tres cosas que alimentan tu
espíritu y confundimos placer con
felicidad por eso es que muchos se meten
en problemas muy difíciles ahora nos ha
tocado atender a gente que están en un
problema de fracaso y tienen necesidad
de salir de allí y hay gente con mucho
éxito que también es miserable porque
los dos tienen hambre en su espíritu
pero hay tres maneras de alimentar tu
espíritu número uno lo que alimenta tu
espíritu es la fe y esta fe no o sea no
se trata de mi religión ni siquiera que
creas lo que yo creo pero la fe es creer
en algo más grande es creer que hay un
origen y hay un destino de nuestras
vidas que que no estamos aquí por
accidente y cada quien tiene su propio
sistema de creencias y cree lo que debe
creer pero en mi caso yo creo en dios y
que el camino hacia mi conexión con dios
es por medio de la fe en cristo jesús y
eso llena mi espíritu y tú tienes que
buscar qué es lo que tú crees y cuál es
tu origen y cuál es tu final y tener esa
comunión
conversación con eso que tú tienes fe
pero la fe llena tu espíritu la segunda
cosa que llena nuestro espíritu es el
amor incondicional todos necesitamos
sentir que somos amados tal y como somos
con o sin pelo con o sin es verdad
defectos todos tenemos algo y todos
queremos sentir que somos bien amados
bien aceptados bien queridos tal y como
somos y eso sana nuestras vidas pero
también el amor incondicional tenemos
que aprender a darlo a otras personas y
yo de nuevo a la gente que tiene mucho
éxito pero si no tiene fe si no
experimenta el amor incondicional si no
tiene a quien amar incondicionalmente
hay un vacío que su espíritu lo está
diciendo tengo hambre hay algo más
entonces fe amor incondicional y número
3 un propósito es muy diferente tener un
trabajo tener una carrera tener una
familia tener amigos a tener propósito
propósito es la causa
grande por la cual tienes amigos carrera
dinero familia cosas propósito yo creo
todos nosotros tenemos el propósito de
hacer mejor la vida de los que nos
rodean de mejorar nuestro mundo de
mejorar nuestro entorno en otras
palabras quizá tu vocación es una de ser
médico pero tu propósito es ayudar y
mejorar la vida de las personas quizá tu
vocación es maestro quizá su vocación es
en el área de la ciencia de la
tecnología o del diseño del arte estuvo
que su trabajo es tu vocación pero tu
propósito es mejorar la vida de la gente
que te rodea a tu alrededor y cuando
encontramos fe cuando encontramos amor
cuando encontramos propósito nuestro
espíritu empieza a experimentar
felicidad un sentir de satisfacción te
imaginas qué pasaría en méxico sin
méxico fuéramos 37 por ciento más
productivos si en nuestro trabajo
fuéramos 37 por ciento más efectivos más
creativos
y productivos en lo que hacemos
podríamos cambiar nuestras familias pero
empezando con el sentir de satisfacción
y felicidad que nuestro espíritu está
buscando y termino con este pensamiento
no sé cuántos de ustedes
cuando tienen hambre se ponen muy de
malas
o conoces a alguien que se pone muy mal
cuando tiene hambre
mi esposa literal se transforma en la
bestia del apocalipsis cuando tiene
hambre no no no le digan que dije eso
pero pero realmente se pone muy mal se
distorsiona sus emociones se pone de
malas se enoja y se frustra mucho cuando
tiene hambre y fuera de broma cuando tú
ves algún lugar a veces en nuestro
méxico a veces en otro país cuando ves a
un niño una persona mal nutrida de forma
incluso su cuerpo entonces un hombre
puede deformar tus emociones pero un
hambre profunda puede deformar incluso
tu cuerpo quizá muchas de las
frustraciones y deformidades de nuestro
carácter y el freno a nuestro éxito o
nuestra productividad o el tope que
experimentamos para una vida plena quizá
es porque hay hambre en nuestro espíritu
es lo que propongo el día de hoy hay que
alimentarlo muchas gracias
[Aplausos]